[Music]
who came up with the three meals a day
anyway food industry yeah I mean city
you know the vested interest you just
start channeling it right and further
back and yeah I mean you know and then I
think he got sustained by our own
emotional needs you know as a substitute
for you know the comfort foods so to
speak and then it became entrenched
conventional wisdom that breakfast is
the most important meal of the day
forever and now that's sort of out the
window it's interesting how these things
change as they should as we learn more
right yeah I um and it's funny when
you're when you're a TV doc doing this
stuff because you know you always get
accused of flip-flopping right that's
the thing one study today another study
tomorrow and you can sort of see why
people get a little annoyed by that and
breakfast was a good example because
I've always said that I think and I
think you and I even had this guy
conversation breakfast like a king lunch
like a prince and dinner like a peasant
you know front-load your calories uh-huh
that made the most sense and and there
were studies that I read said well you
will eat fewer calories in throughout
the day you won't have as many cravings
all the sort of stuff you'll be more
productive earlier in the day and then
the study comes out that says actually
if you eat a big breakfast you're not
likely to lose weight are you kidding me
and first of all they blame me this idea
yeah and somehow it's your fault right
exactly but you know the thing about it
is that those studies are just really
hard to do mm-hmm
almost all of them they count on people
recalling their meals really well they
count on people being honest about what
they and super unreliable super
unreliable and then if you actually
looked at the data that the difference
in weight was about 1.6 pounds now it's
not nothing but you know it's not you
know sort of earth-shattering either but
but the but these sort of binary
responses breakfast no longer get uh-huh
you know that that ends up being the
headline and you know if you if people
want to dig just a just another layer
under the surface they get a more
complete picture of things so I still
think breakfast is the most important
meal yeah
and have you experimented with
intermittent fasting yeah I in fact I
did
Valter Longo x' program where I did the
five days and I ate the sort of you know
the meal replacements which I guess was
probably under 500 calories a day and
the one thing he said to me and I
experienced it was sort of by end of day
two you think you're hungry day one end
of day two I felt great uh-huh I
actually felt like I probably had more
energy than a guy who'd just eaten 500
calories for the entire day and he says
it's because all of a sudden your body
is forced into this production of new
stem cells right and it gives you this
jolt of energy and I anecdotally I felt
it right how about on day five day say
how long did you do it well it's I did I
did five days and I'll tell you by day
five I sort of thought to myself I had a
fleeting thought that if this was the
rest of my life I could probably do it
right I could I could do it I probably
have days where I splurge from time to
time but for the most part eating you
know a low calorie diet like that I you
know once I got past the first day and a
half I found it not that not that
challenging right yeah yeah it's cool I
mean I've been doing intermittent
fasting where I just eat dinner and I
I've kind of acclimated to that like
even when I'm training I find unless I'm
training really hard and it's not
something I would recommend doing all
the time but to kind of tap into that
once in a while yeah it's empowering too
because you realize like I don't you
don't have to be dependent on these
things that you think you can't go more
than a couple hours without yeah yeah
and I always people must ask you all the
time like how you travel all the time
how do you what do you do on airplanes
you're right everything's constantly
it's like well at the most
you're lucky unless you're going
intercontinental you're looking at five
or six hours right right they give a
deal really true are you some nuts yeah
something like that and you can get by
don't get sucked into the bad snacks and
all that kind of stuff you won't you'll
regret that decision stay hydrated you
know try and get some sleep you know the
basic sort of apply for sure but I think
that not not sort of saying well I
deserve to to be able to break a bad
break a habit and do something like a
cheat food or whatever you don't you
don't necessary know that's the things
just because you're traveling so I try
and be good about it you know even if
I'm on the road you're on the road all
the time though aren't ya
no I I'm on the road a lot in some ways
I find that I can be more disciplined on
the road I'm the only person that I'm
accountable to on the road is me yeah
when I'm home I have my wife and I have
three kids and you know I gotta be a
team player mm-hmm so you know if a meal
may involve something that I otherwise
would not eat
am I gonna be obstinate and say you know
I've refused it you know or make
everyone else eat what I want to eat you
know it's you know it's just it's it's
it's living luckily you know my wife who
you've you've met is is she's interested
in the same things that I am and our
kids have developed really good palates
we used to stick all kinds of food on
their highchair tray when they were
babies and let them just try different
things and I think they developed good
interesting palates as a results they
like all all different foods yeah yeah
yeah well yeah that's good that's
encouraging I mean it's hard to get kids
eating healthy yeah I know although like
you've always said and even you said
last night is that I think that our
default position probably is to want to
eat food out of the ground it's it's
it's very it's very natural it's you
know if left to our own devices and no
no exposure to all the other things
around us advertising and all these
other choices we probably would eat you
know as humans a very specific way would
be a good way to eat but that exposure
is a problem and when you have kids they
are exposed to those things and you're
not always controlling their environment
and so it becomes a bit of a dance
because you know yeah well I'm really
excited to have you here it means a lot
that you would take time out of your
busy schedule to sit with me and there's
just a couple things I want to say and
you know publicly one is is that since I
started this podcast you bet at the top
of my list as somebody I wanted to thank
you have this conversation with and just
to kind of create a little context you
have played a massive role
whether you're aware of it or not in my
own personal story you know back in
2008-2009 when I started doing these
ultra events and trying to figure out
how it was going to change my life and
having made certain progress in that
regard I was still you know practicing
law and very unhappy in that and trying
to you know sort of read the tarot cards
about what would come next and you
unbeknownst to me had taken an interest
in my story and came out here we did a
story I wrote a little blog post for CNN
and it really changed the trajectory of
my life I mean that was you know perhaps
from your perspective you know just an
interesting small gesture but it was one
that really kind of moved the tectonic
plates on how I thought about what I do
and the possibilities for what it could
become
and you really catalyzed an energy in me
and have encouraged me from afar and
sort of mentored me from afar to kind of
blaze this path that I'm on so I just
wanted to thank you for that and
acknowledge that it's been super
meaningful to me rich thank you I mean
that's that's means a lot to me I want
to where we have these mics in front of
us other than I mean across the table
and give you a hug
yeah that means a lot that you that you
tell that story and you know we don't
know sometimes about you know how life's
gonna unfold or the people that we're
gonna meet and I definitely felt like
when we met and and I was super inspired
by your story you know just just what
you had overcome and and I think we're
all trying to overcome something and
even in my own life at the time I was
trying to overcome things so selfish in
a way because I draw off your energy but
then you you've I'm so proud of you and
I think everyone's so proud of you and
looks at you as a beacon of inspiration
when I'm when I'm working out and I'm
digging deep and I feel like I cannot
dig any deeper and I think of you well I
think of ritual I think of that picture
undercover find their ultra no seriously
you really you really are I mean in
there's you the majority of people that
you've inspired of people you will never
meet you know there's just all these
people out there who who you you touch
and I mentioned your name I say I'm
gonna see you and
you know they they know you they're
inspired by you you've you've changed
their lives so I I appreciate that I've
done something small for you because
you've done something so much for so
many people I appreciate that and and
you're a big reason of you know why I
started this podcast and kind of wanted
to propagate and spread this message of
health and yeah this and longevity and
fitness and all the things you know that
we that we both love so let's get into
it a little bit I mean the first you
know you you have a really interesting
story and trajectory of how you BK you
know I'm always interested in the
superhero origin story you do so many
things in addition to being the chief
medical correspondent for CNN I mean
you're doing docu-series or you do
60-minute you're still doing 60 minutes
right now that's on hold I gotta you
know gotta make decisions in terms yeah
writing books and yeah you had a
television show for a while in the
mornings like how do you balance all of
this I think you need to be realistic at
any given time in terms of what you're
you're taking on you know there's
there's it's it's a full life but I
think for me all these various things
fit together in some way I don't think
of them as independent things I think
you know if you're if you're doing a lot
of things in life no matter what what
they are finding time to really figure
out what the connective tissue is
between these things makes a big
difference it makes it easier for you to
organize your time to prioritize things
to figure out how you can get multiple
sort of use out of something like if
you're working on something and you
think well that could also be beneficial
to another project or to somebody else
who's working on something to make sure
that you're constantly collaborating
that way and sharing I mean for me you
know medicine and health and wellness
has always been the common denominator
mmm I continue to practice medicine you
know which is my first and truest love
that kind of pulls everything together
but the idea that you know when I see
patients in the office 90% of them don't
need an operation they just need to be
educated about something yeah through
television we're sort of doing the same
thing you know the the docu-series to me
was based on the realization that that
when I teach people things stories are
what matter
stories of what really forced something
into the brain make it memorable and
make it more likely to be shared so it's
still teaching it's still educating my
patients or potential patients but just
in different ways so I learned something
one place I apply it somewhere else and
it's busy but it's really good really
good how often are you practicing
medicine what does that aspect of your
schedule look you know on paper it's
it's sort of like a 50/50 split I mean I
operate Irby Monday uh-huh every other
Friday I see patients in the office on
Thursdays I think people would be really
surprised to hear that I would imagine
most people don't realize that you're
actually still practicing doc yeah I I
know it's it's funny and it's it's it's
funny for me because that that is still
very much how I see myself you know I
mean I started thinking about medicine
when I was 16 years old and I finished
medical school 26 years ago now and I've
been practicing neurosurgery you know
for forget 20 years and so it's it's um
it's a big part of my life and and I you
know I think I see everything through
that lens still through medicine through
neuroscience through you know my
interests in the brain spinal cord and
all that but but I've in some ways kept
those parts of my life a little
separated I never want it and the people
at CNN are so good at I operate on
Mondays they know that they can leave me
alone Ronnie's not like everything that
is not yeah typically but you know it's
but it's it's gonna be busy sometimes
you'll get breaking news and things that
but you know they they all say and and I
say that you know the obviously my
hospital life and Hospital world comes
first right I mean I see myself as a
doctor first and and luckily they see
the world that way as well and they're
very respectful of it so 18 years now
I've been doing this and it's that sort
of blended life has sort of worked out
yeah yeah so you grow up in Michigan
mm-hmm a precocious smart kid born to
Indian immigrants yeah very first
general your parents are first
generation generation
yeah mom was born in what is now Lahore
Pakistan and people know of maybe this
partition that happened in 47 led to the
greatest largest I should say human
migration really in history all through
South Asia my mom was one of those
people there's a five year old kid who
then lived as a refugee for the first
dozen or so years of her life my dad was
from northern India you know they they
ended up meeting in the States which is
very unusual for people for Indians who
got married at that time it was almost
all arranged marriages it's kind of a
funny story my mom is goes to school in
Oklahoma comes here to go to engineering
school she wants to become the first
woman engineer in the automotive
industry
so drives from Oklahoma to Detroit
that's you know that's where the cars
are being made and ironically enough her
car breaks down in Ann Arbor so she's
immigrant from the other side of the
world on this this mission to become the
first woman engineer in the automotive
industry she has no friends no money
broken down car uh-huh and what do you
do right you're in a strange town so you
go to the phone book and you look for
Indian sounding names yeah yeah that's
what it was like right go do an actual
phone booth then you pick up an actual
phone book and and you look up names and
so most common Indian name Patel writes
all right
goes and finds the Patel calls a cold
call cold calls and but you know when
you're when you're living in such a
small you know community of people at
that point nothing's a cold call because
everybody everybody is so they want to
take care of each other and they want
they want they're really invested in
everyone's success so calls this Patel
guy but he's not home his roommate is
whose last name is Gupta Wow
mmm her future husband that's of my
father so what is this like late 50s or
60s no it's late 60s at 66 67 that
timeframe right and so they they get
married and it's a it's a love marriage
which is again it's all arranged
marriages at that time but a love
marriage you know unbelievable that it
could have
and it did and you know that was what 50
yeah yeah you come out three years later
basically they didn't waste any time
that was quicker than that yeah there
was a real love marriage and did she
become an engineer in the automotive
industry she became an engineer in the
automotive industry and she was the
first woman ever hired as in Wow an
engineer which is which is kind of
incredible she she for a woman who was a
refugee on the other side of the world
for the first 12 years of her life sees
some book about Henry Ford when she's in
a library sometime and says that that's
it
that's absolutely what I heard ooh mmm
and you know there's this is India I
mean the girls didn't even go to school
let alone go to college go to grad
school talk about becoming an engineer
and so she did it we're very proud of
her you know that that that was coming
from being a refugee yeah seven years he
said 1212 my word 12 years and it's it's
interesting I you know she's the only
person I I know obviously that lived
that life and you know it's it's it's
interesting because her way of dealing
with people her way of navigating
herself through situations her way of
not taking no for an answer you know
just being so so so steadfast and and
how she approaches things I think in
some ways comes from her life as a
refugee
you know a little girl in a refugee camp
you've got to figure things out and
that's I think it's she's tough she's a
tough lady if you met her you love her
but you'd also see that you know someone
who's who's clearly been toughened by
that but yeah she um she got the job as
the first woman engineer and and you
know this I think in a lot of ways
opened up that path for a lot of other
future Women Engineers yeah so did that
make her a taskmaster as a mother yeah I
imagine a very you know sort of
education focused very very education
focus and very you can't do that I'm
sorry is that what you said you can't do
that if I ever said I can't do that mom
I'm sorry I don't understand you can't
do that or you won't you know it's just
it was very it was there was always this
sort of feeling like
she never she never held it over us that
let me show you what my life was like
although we all need a story but the
idea that we would think of something is
too challenging or too hard or you know
whatever it was probably never gonna be
an acceptable excuse for her so I can't
was not something that was sad dealer
yeah and you know my dad's different you
know my dad is much more easygoing much
more lackadaisical in this regard so
that was always an interesting tension
as well in the house you know going to
the dad instead of the mom for things
knowing who to go to for what exactly so
what kind of kid were you
I grew up in a really small town right
very homogenous small town the only
Indian family living there very very
middle-class you know sort of lot of
people who are neighbors also worked in
the auto industry but mostly on the line
you know more blue-collar workers my
parents were young really young when
they had me early 20s so I was I think
it was a it was a it was a good
childhood because my parents were were
very invested in me and you know my dad
you know was a student of mathematics
and taught mathematics and he want to
spend a lot of time with me just
teaching me things so it was good in
that regard but it was a tough time I
think as well being you know Indian
living in a in a town like that that
where I was the only person who looked
like I did I had that sense of other
Ness yeah that sense and it was
everything right it was the type of name
you had the food that you ate the the
religion the cultural beliefs in the
middle of it the Iran hostage crisis
happens and suddenly anyone who's darker
skinned is is really ostracized you know
even even people didn't make any
distinctions you either you know
American or you weren't and so there was
there was that part of it but but I
think overall I think it was it was a
good it was a good childhood I mean I
because of my parents I was a lot like I
think about things and dream about
things and my mom was a big dreamer you
know so she encouraged that when was the
doctor dream born you know it was it was
it was interesting for me because
neither one of my parents are physicians
like a lot of my friends who went into
medicine and who are my you know sort of
medical colleagues now or sort of came
from generational families of doctors in
some ways it was just that was their
their fate no matter what my parents
were not doctors and in medicine you
know going to medical school and all
that was a pretty audacious thing in
terms of cost and time and all that so
there wasn't like a lot of Indian
families I think you know we won our son
or daughter to be a doctor that was that
wasn't necessary the thinking in my
house my grandfather my mom's father got
sick when I was young 12 or 13 years old
and was in the hospital and I you know
were very close so we spent a lot of
time together and I think was the first
time I really got exposed to hospitals
and doctors and in this case
neurosurgeons because of his he had a
stroke and he ended up having to have a
procedure to open up his artery his
carotid artery and I think it was the
first time that I started thinking about
medicine
I wasn't necessary thing about
neurosurgery at that point but just
thinking about medicine as a career like
science I like the idea that you could
be a doctor in the healthcare world and
help people as a as a job yeah that was
sounded really interesting so it was
around that time and it sort of sort of
grew from there
right you end up going to University of
Michigan yeah and you are part of the
into flux program right which is less
this fast track to becoming a doctor
yeah combined medical school and
undergrad right yeah that you like get
your degree as quickly as possible yeah
you've done your homework I know a
couple other people that have done
they've discontinued that program they
discontinued it yeah it's really so it
was a program that was basically
designed to to anticipate what they
thought was gonna be this this primary
care doctor shortage in the United
States so they wanted to - basically
from a young age get people interested
in in primary care and the way that they
did that was they accepted you into
medical school out of high school you
just you had to do two years of college
and then you started your medical school
classes so it was much shorter and my
parents liked it goes is much cheaper
you're saving two years of tuition yeah
but I think part of the reason that it
got discontinued ultimately was that the
idea that people would go into primary
care fields only you didn't it just
didn't necessarily pan out that way and
I went into neurosurgery and specialized
field friends of mine and ophthalmology
or other other specialized field so but
it was a great opportunity if you were
certain you wanted to be a doctor and I
made that decision at 16 years old
there gonna be a doctor which is you
know my kids 13 I can't imagine I make a
decision which is you know really not
positioned yeah I think what is it Erik
Erikson I think you know the the the
evolutionary psychologist he talks about
the fact that really not until our mid
30s
uh-huh should we be making any important
decisions about job about marriage about
whatever you know I mean listen I didn't
start figuring it out until my mid
forties I don't know how somebody is
supposed to know what their they're
supposed to be doing at that age is
crazy I know if your system is set up to
the fur that we're supposed to know yeah
you you you you you need to develop that
those decisions and have that inertia
the sort of carries you in that
direction early on otherwise you feel
like you're behind you yeah you've
missed the boat your life is over
yeah that's crazy so where does that
where do you begin your practice then so
you know the way the neuro surgery works
after you finish med school you do train
and training for nursery seven years
long so it's very it's the longest which
again wasn't something that my parents
appreciate it too much because you're
still going into debt during that time
you're making some money but you still
have a lot of debt from med school then
I did a fellowship on top of that so it
was like eight years long seven and a
half eight years long and then I stayed
on at the University of Michigan for a
while I had trained there when did my
fellowship elsewhere came back and
stayed on faculty there and then a few
years after that moved to Atlanta and
the Emory Clinic and Emory Clinic has
sort of been home for teenagers right so
how does the whole media career begin
somebody knock on your door and say hey
you got a face for telling me
the its it's it's really serendipitous
and and you know there's there's no
strategy here and so like people when
I'm trying to give people advice on
lending their lives with something else
I have to remind them that sometimes you
just gotta accept things that are
serendipitous so for me I you know in
the midst of this when I was in my
training I got really interesting health
care policy and writing about it and I
worked at the White House for a while
mostly writing about health care policy
working as a White House Fellow it's
like it early 2000s when you were doing
this is late 90s 97 108 so Clinton
administration and you know the White
House felt and then very incident health
care and wrote speeches on health care
for First Lady and the president and was
interesting is that there was a guy who
was running CNN at the time named Tom
Johnson who who would oftentimes come
around the White House and there's sort
of a porous border I think between
public service and White House work and
media you see a lot nowadays right
people sort of going from White House
work then they're becoming analysts or
provides on television it was happening
back then as well and and Tom wanted to
build a medical unit he that was his
desire he he had been a newspaper guy at
the LA Times ran the LA Times now was
doing television knew that medical and
health and wellness was just a really
important thing that he didn't think was
getting enough coverage he wanted to
build a medical unit and this was 97 he
talked to me about this and I frankly
didn't know what that meant
it was there was no context for it you
know there was occasionally medical
reports on television but like an entire
medical unit you know what would that do
what would it be doing when it wasn't
actively doing television all that sort
of stuff so I kind of I kind of you know
we kept in touch but I didn't really
understand what what that sort of work
would entail four years later five years
later I moved to Atlanta to take this
job at the Emory clinic and I run into
Tom physically uh-huh physically run
into him in the airport and he's this
big guy and he's got this booming deep
voice you know so joy Gupta tell him
Johnson good to see you you remember me
you should come by CNN and um I said
sure you know
here now buff to see CNN I'm a news
junkie and I and I go to the CNN
NEWSROOM in Atlanta and it just blew my
mind it was this amazing place where you
got all these people in the middle of
this news room who are basically taking
in whatever news is happening anywhere
in the world
and they're hearing it and they're
trying to determine if it's something
that should be reported and if it's
going to be reported how will they do it
do they send people to go to the area
where the news is happening and all this
stuff just curious people who somehow
had their fingers on the pulse of the
world's news and I thought that'd be
really interesting yeah any part of that
and so prior to this there was no sort
of health department at CNN of any
formal nature right it there was there
were people who sort of had niche
interests in medical and health and
wellness stories and but not now you
have an entire unit where that's that's
what they that their medical producers
and I work in this particular unit that
is there that is that the types of
stories that they're always interested
in pursuing and looking at so it's it's
totally different I think in some ways
because of Tom over the last 20 years
right so he says come onboard you say
okay and then yeah I mean so the so not
just keep in mind the timing here is
really interesting because it was August
of 2001 and and you know it's first term
first year of george w bush's presidency
and i'm a healthcare policy guy right
besides practicing neurosurgery
healthcare policies kind of how he knows
me from the white house stuff he's like
you can talk about you know the
president's new health care plan because
it was a health care plan back then as
well and then you know not even a month
three and a half weeks after I started
9/11 9/11 and the world changes
you know everybody's world changed and
my world the ER world i briefed and they
said to me hey look you know we're
probably not going to be doing health
policy for a while on television I mean
this is this is you know one of the
biggest stories in the world what do you
think about covering this story instead
you know being in New York doing doing
reports on people who
who didn't die but didn't really survive
either you know the sort of badly
injured and we did in hospitals there
was the anthrax attacks that October and
then you know the the conflicts in
Afghanistan and Iraq which have been
ongoing stories for my entire career
here and I was always interested in how
people take care of each other in
battlefield situations so all of a
sudden like within a month my world
again everybody's world but my world
real right really changed yeah so you
think you're gonna be this talking head
on exactly political policy yeah and
then you end up becoming embedded over
in Iraq right yeah yeah exactly I mean I
watched the Gulf War on television in 91
and and I was riveted I remember I was
in college and and I just remember the
greenish screen on TV and seeing the
bright lights and like is what is that
those missiles going up or those bombs
falling you know what am I looking at
and but you knew that people were
getting injured and that there were
people who were rushing in to help them
which I just I it still gives me chills
when I think about it you know just
total strangers and you're going in and
and risking your life to to help them it
just felt like the most human of all
stories and I was just curious how it
even happened like right where were the
the nurses and doctors stationed how do
they get in what do they have with them
what sorts of injuries were they seeing
and you know all that stuff so when you
know the possibility of me going into
Iraq as an embedded reporter with the
first Marine Expeditionary Force and a
group of doctors known as the devil
Doc's I I really wanted to go I want to
you know I never done anything like that
before in my life but I knew that I
wanted to be there and what was the
reality of that experience in the
context of what you imagined it to be or
what perhaps we think you know just from
seeing it on television I think I think
one of the maybe not surprising to
people in in the military world but you
know as somebody who lives a pretty
fast-paced life what you find in in
in a conflict situation like that is
that 90 95 percent of the time it is it
is just totally quiet
there's just nothing happening you know
it's still it's almost deafening lis
quiet in the middle of the desert and
you you're sitting there and you know
you pitch your tent and it's it's like
sure boredom you know and you end up
having conversations with people and
having these really deep conversations
with people because first of all you
have the time and second of all there's
this sort of overlying veneer that
something really bad could happen at any
moment you just don't know when and that
kind of makes forces these deeper sort
of conversations and relationships about
things that you otherwise wouldn't talk
about and then you have this whiplash
right going from just sheer boredom to
to utter terror you know back and forth
and I think that that's that's was one
of the the surprising things to me I
just imagine that was always gonna be
sort of like hustle bustle and
constantly strategic like he always knew
where the enemy was and they knew where
you were and you know you were
constantly sort of strategizing you know
like I think of Vietnam or Korea like
you fight a war across a line here it
was hopscotching around the desert
nobody really knowing for certain what
was about to happen you could be riding
along on a cowboy ride on a beautiful
day just staring at the sky and I was
sudden you're you come under fire and
you think oh my god I could die you know
right now and and I was just fine
looking at the sky a second ago so
things like wait I'm a neurosurgeon why
am I not back at the hospital yeah
there's a surreal aspect to your life in
your career
there must be moments in which you're
like how did I end up here yeah well in
no doubt
and and you and I think what's what's
really important and I think it's true
for anybody in any any field or anything
they do is you can't say have to remind
yourself of why you're doing what you're
doing you know I mean like covering a
war and you know I get young kids at
home and and my wife obviously you know
there was times when when things were
really looking pretty bleak when I
thought god I am stupid you know
I'm just stupid I'm gonna die out here
and and then you know you remind
yourself that the stories that you tell
and getting this this this information
out there is important you know you've
got to see it as important otherwise you
probably shouldn't do it because the the
price is too high to pay you know
otherwise so and and and covering
conflicts I think are a time when you
really really remind yourself of that
like I really understand the importance
of what we do and why we do it yeah well
there's also an excitement to it and an
energy to it I mean this is something
I've talked with Dan Harris about like
he he got so into it yet he couldn't
stop becoming you know going overseas
and being involved in conflict to the
point where it really eroded his health
and he had PTSD and all these issues as
a result of that yeah and and and you
know and Dan's obviously a great example
of someone who's been able to find
really effective ways to deal with that
but yeah i think i think you there is an
addictive quality to it I mean there is
I think that's probably physiologic
probably not different in some ways and
what you experienced with all your your
exercise but you get that adrenaline
rush and it's it's it's feels really
good I mean you get these spikes of
adrenaline where you're like oh my god
like you guys it's almost too much and
then when you come down from it it's
like it's it's it's pretty appealing you
can see why people want that sort of
feeling from time to time and I you know
I definitely definitely have that you
know when we in working in a place like
CNN when there is breaking news when
something big is breaking there's
nothing like it right I mean the entire
company just comes together it's
galvanized and as a group that I have
not seen anything quite like that so and
so I see the allure to it I was in New
York City I can't even remember why but
I went over to CNN to go see Ronnie yeah
who runs your unit
what's her official job title what is
her official job title night it's
executive or the executive producer and
I'm sitting with her and we're catching
up and right as we're talking the Boston
Marathon
happened so I was actually right with
her when that occurred and I got to see
the whole newsroom jump into action yeah
figure out like what's going on how are
we gonna cover this what do we know what
do we not know it was amazing
it's it's you know I mean if there's
things that sort of allow a organization
to to click on all cylinders to really
you know use their talents to the max
obviously tragic situation but in terms
of breaking news CNN when that happens
it's it's unlike anything I've ever seen
I mean the closest thing I think would
be when you're working in a trauma
hospital and a in a child comes in who's
been the victim of trauma mm-hmm and all
of a sudden you know you get people
coming out of the woodwork who are just
like there to help people come in from
home and you know it's just like
everything everybody comes together and
takes care of this and it's the same
sort of thing with a big story like that
and by the way you've got a lot of you
know before we actually start
broadcasting and on television there's
so many moving parts there's the
editorial judgment like what are we
seeing here exactly what are we willing
to say on television you know our
families who's whose loved ones been
affected do they know or are they gonna
hear about it the first on TV you know
how do we make sure that doesn't happen
because you know people should should
have the courtesy of hearing these
things without the rest of the world
hearing it at the same time yeah
balancing that responsibility against
this increasing pressure to be for right
to be fast that's right and and you know
I mean that that is a at San interesting
thing as someone who came to television
sort of more mid-career
I think if you if you grew up with with
the world of TV journalism that becomes
this really important metric I need to
beat the other guy by you know 15
seconds you know I never saw the the the
real appeal of in that because I felt
like if you could wait the extra you
know time and tell a much better more
complete story or picture it was worth
it and I think in the medical you know
we have the luxury of doing that you
know we there's absolutely no no benefit
at all for us being early and even
possibly being wrong
it was just know it that's you know you
trust is the most important thing yeah
so how do you think about CNN and its
responsibilities in this kind of culture
of you know fake news and fast news and
you know all the kind of epithets that
you know now I mean how do you process
that or what are your thoughts on it's
it's it's hard it's it's hard because
you you know no one ever probably looks
at anything in life and says I have a
hundred percent confidence in this I
mean there's what things in our life are
absolute honest brokers are true nor
stars very few things I mean you know
small businesses in your community you
know mom-and-pop stores those are the
military there are certain organizations
that tend to be very very high trust
organizations but just about everything
else government media even mainstream
medicine there's always a bit of
suspicion or distrust so anything that
sort of opens up that that that crevice
even more the president calling you know
CN n fake news gives voice to you know
people sometimes totally unsubstantiated
suspicions but but just gives it voice
all of a sudden so you you know it makes
it hard you you you have to in some ways
you don't do anything different than you
normally do you you want to make sure
that you're right you're accurate you're
maintain that level of trust that
relationship with the audience but yeah
it's hard I think it's really hard
probably for the political reporters
because in right in some ways this may
even be dangerous for them because
people they get really angry and you
know they they people there's people who
you know who worry about their own
physical safety as a result of these I
think largely unfounded suspicions but
it's it's been challenging yeah yeah
well the temperature is different than
it was just a few years ago and you know
some of that that that there there can
be a healthy mistrust and that sort of
puts the pressure on the media yeah
maintain that level of integrity and
honesty but when it tips over into you
know insanity world I would imagine it
makes your job more difficult
but yeah I mean you're not you know
overtly reporting on politics you're you
know you keep breaking news around
health but most of what you do are these
long-form kind of heavily researched
longtail stories yeah and and that's
that's a that's a real luxury certainly
in our world of television to be able to
to really dig into topics to have
programming time long enough to be able
to tell these stories and you know so
you feel very lucky when you get to be
able to do it but yeah you you you you
have everything really buttoned up I
mean you you spend the most of the time
producing something like this a
long-form medical story is is the
research is the background and then you
know telling the story part of it comes
very naturally but we you know the facts
and the evidence and all that really
kind of lead the way with these types of
stories I feel like I get to get a mini
masters degree and you know thousand
different topics which is a lot of fun
yeah well you're very deft at
communicating your communication skills
are amazing and you have this I sort of
see you as somebody who is steeped in
the science and has this you know
history and experience in medicine and
all its facets but you know how to take
that information and translate it in a
way that the everyday American can
actually not only understand it but like
digest it and then implement it into
some kind of tangible behavior change I
appreciate that and means a lot coming
from yeah I mean you get a lot of
scientists like they can't communicate
with the public like they don't you know
that means so it doesn't matter what
they're saying because it's not
penetrating yeah I think that you know
it's it's interesting because I think
there's sort of two aspects I think when
it comes to health medical science
reporting part of it is I think just an
intrigue like people are interested in
science as a general thing I just want
to understand the science of this how
would that work in the body but the vast
majority of people when they hear these
stories they you immediately place
yourself in that situation how does this
affect me or how does this affect people
that I love you know this this new thing
and whether it be some new breakthrough
in an immunotherapy drug for cancer
or breakfast isn't necessary the most
important meal of the day whatever it
may be true like truly empathy takes on
a different meaning here in the sense
that I really want to put myself in the
viewer or listeners position here
they're hearing this and are they
screaming at the TV going whoa what does
that mean or wait you said the exact
opposite thing yesterday or whatever
they might be saying truly sort of
anticipating how they're going to react
to something and and you know crafting a
message that you think you would want to
hear you know something that would be
important to you or relevant to you in
your life so it's it's in and there's
times when you get scientific studies
that are you know they're they are
scientific studies they're in journals
you know they're they've been peer
reviewed but they still lack a certain
common sense to the way that the
conclusions were drawn breakfast no
longer important because people on
average over a certain period of time
weighed a pound and a half more you know
let's let's look into that study really
do they have that how do they know what
people age where people honest about
what they ate you know to really look at
data and also apply a common sense
filter to it which after doing this for
you know 18 years and turning 50 this
year you know at some point in life you
figure look look I've earned the ability
to to analyze this and not just
regurgitate facts and data I should be
not just an antenna that's receiving
information then putting it out there I
should be able to actually process this
and make it a value in some way it's not
to adulterate it or add my own editorial
spin to it as much as it is to make it
accessible and relevant to viewers
here's what I took away from this study
here's why this is important here's why
it may not be as important as you think
here's the headline you're gonna read
tomorrow but let me let me give you a
couple caveats on that headline you know
as you as you read this that sort of
thing I think it's how I've looked at
the world so being able to apply it to
to journalism in some ways it was a very
natural fit yeah but you didn't go to
journalism school you went to medical
school right I don't they don't teach
this skill in medical school like how
did you learn did you have mentors at
CNN that helped you
learn this kind of crafted storytelling
um yeah you know you certainly learned
from you know there's people who I work
with and television that are I think
just like Ben tinker who's here is just
a natural storyteller you just got
really great instincts on things in
terms of what I'm talking about
but but I do think there there are some
parallels between medicine and media
this way my wife Rebecca who you know
and you um she loves to tell the story
because you know she ends up looking
really good in it which she should
because but the I when I first started
doing television you know I'm I
naturally 'king style it was not to be
enunciated my words very clearly
necessarily and I stutter a lot and I
pause for periods of time that are maybe
longer than seems normal
you know and things like that and and it
was just my sort of speaking style she
reminded me like when I'm talking to
patients in the clinic you know in the
office like what was it that I was
trying to convey to these patients first
of all they came in in search of
something you know so to really be
empathetic to that to not be dismissive
of how people are approaching an issue
or how they're thinking about an issue
to is that I really want them to
understand what I'm saying so I need to
make sure that what I'm telling them is
factual but I got it I got a fine
language and find a way of communicating
it that they're really gonna understand
it and then to you know to take the time
to you know if there's questions around
it to be able to really answer those
questions in some ways televisions the
same thing the lens became the patient
in some ways and I think that was a
click moment for me when when she told
me that and for the first time I could
look at a lens and not be totally
freaked out by it right I mean would
literally like look away from it like I
was in some sort of hostage action
program
yeah witness protection program and and
now I can you know try and make a better
connection I think then I used to be
able to and find the right words and and
not stammer and stutter and you know
have these weird pauses as much yeah one
of the things that that I've noticed
with increasing regularity is the
frequency with which a scientific paper
or study
come out and there'll be a new cycle
around it with crazy
clickbait titles that have no bearing on
what that study actually said and
completely mischaracterize it
characterizes it to the extent that it's
all it is it becomes fake news right and
this is what generates interest this
kind of hyperbole yeah and it's rampant
and completely out of control there's an
irresponsibility out there with how
we're reporting science and medicine
yeah and I think with science and
medicine I think the stakes in the bar
have to be even higher than than other
things because people make decisions in
their life sure based on this sometimes
small decisions sometimes big decisions
but always important decisions I think
that one thing is is there's a lot of
you know I'll call them fly-by-night
organizations organizations that aren't
really interested in being around for
the long haul
they come in they want to they create a
lot of content quickly they use
clickbait headlines and their goal is to
basically you know make make as much
money as they can by generating a
certain readership and viewership but
they they don't they're not investing as
much in the long term relationship with
the consumer because the consumers read
the articles at a company a clickbait
headline and they say well wait hang out
a second these don't match up the
headline and what you put in the article
don't match up and after a while you it
just becomes a violation of trust and so
but it can last long enough a couple of
years for companies to you know have
generated revenue get acquired do
whatever and then they're out I mean I
think you know there is an advantage of
working at a company that has been
around for a long time has as an
interest in being around for a much
longer time because they they take the
the sacred relationship between you know
the producer of the content and the
consumer they take that very seriously
and you know we you know we try and be
careful about that I am sure that
there's examples you could point to at
cnn.com of that exact thing but I would
daresay I think it's further and fewer
between it's not at other places yeah
well the good news is
we've never seen more interest in health
and wellness I mean this is really you
know something that people are keen
about in a way that didn't exist in
Prior generations or even a decade ago
like people really wanted know the kind
of information that you're imparting and
I wonder I'm interested in your thoughts
on this I wonder whether like if I you
know I'm sure I live in a silo in a
bubble where you know I'm reading about
all kinds of new wellness tactics and my
strategies and things like that
but is this really is this trend
penetrating the mainstream in a
meaningful way you know like I saw
somebody tweeted the other day in my
Twitter feed I see people arguing that
we should only plant and then other
people arguing that we should only eat
meat the carnivores but I go out in the
world and I just see people eating
donuts right so it's definitely not
penetrating that yeah I think I think I
think you you sort of have said this but
this idea that that wellness has taken
on a bit of an elitist Sheen then it's
become sort of a privilege of the more
wealthy or the people who have more
resources and I think there's probably
some degree of truth to that you know to
simply practice healthy behaviors for
some reason seems like much more of a
luxury rather than a than a necessity or
a basic right for people I think that
the first part where people are very
interested in this is is true and that
surprised me a bit you know you survive
I sort of imagine people would go get
their information about health and
wellness you know from their doctors or
from their nurses from from medical
establishments and when I started doing
this work I realized that there's a real
appetite for this type of knowledge in
other ways television magazines Internet
and things like that and keep in mind
this is 18 years ago that I started so
obviously now you see that but eighteen
years ago even there was a huge huge
appetite a medical content in these ways
but I think that I think that the the
the idea of do I trust it right I think
I think going back to the suspicion
thing people will get this knowledge but
part of the reason it may not always
penetrate is because do I trust it as
someone just trying to make a buck off
of me or they they there's some vested
interest that I'm missing here or if I'm
looking up a new drug is it just the
pharma company or do I really trust the
government's recommendations on diet
whatever it might be like who are who
are the honest brokers when it comes to
health and wellness who are the people
who I say they have no other vested
interest and other than giving me good
reliable knowledge that will help my
life in some way and you know it's it's
hard to find and and what we see in the
news cycle with what's happening the
pharmaceutical industry and yeah even
with certain government guidelines you
know the the the diet plans a change
year to year I think that just makes
that sort of that makes it worse it
makes it hard to find that honest broker
you have the same the same trends that
give rise to mistrust of the media you
know provide mistrust create mistrust in
the medical establishment in general
yeah I'm a suitable industry people are
even questioning whether their doctors
really know what they're talking yeah
sure and again there's a seed of a seed
of that is healthy but at the same time
and this internet world that we live in
you know this gives rise to the flat
earthers and you know all kinds of crazy
ideas and it makes it difficult and
challenging for the well-intentioned
consumer to just find reliable
information that that's bankable yeah
III I I'm curious I don't know how you
even approach this sort of thing I mean
I have my own sort of strategies in
terms of how I find my own I'm calling
them honest brokers just as a metaphor
but you know where the where are the
places that really don't seem to have
any sort of conflict right because if
you have conflict now look there's no
reason that a university shouldn't be
able to raise money to help fund their
research labs and you know keep the keep
the hospital you know if
and all that sort of stuff but if if
there's real conflicts here if you may
now make a decision that you otherwise
wouldn't have made or reach a conclusion
that you otherwise would not have
reached because of a financial
relationship with with something or
someone or whatever that's obviously a
problem and if it happens once I think
the the trust is totally totally
violated so it's it's hard to find I
mean I I'm not you know I'd like to
think that we in in the world of
journalism get to do that I feel like
I've had a chance to do that because I
don't you know I don't take any money
from anyone other than my employers you
know I don't have any any conflicts
whatsoever where sometimes people find
hard to believe they just assume
everyone has vested interests in some
way but I've been you know really really
diligent about that because not only
because it's I don't think it's right
but also because once it gets in your
head space I think it's very hard then
to be objective on things you know if
you feel like even in the back of your
mind you may have some kind of conflict
I think it's really hard to be objective
but but I think it's harder for people
to find those honest brokers who are
truly objective in their lives
and you know that makes it challenging
for this stuff to penetrate so then how
do you vet your information sources it's
so this is a it's a big process for me
you know I it's first of all even
reading a medical journal article so you
know people will say well it's
peer-reviewed it's a double blinded
randomized control trial nuff said right
that's it I I think I have the ability
now to to look at the stuff and and
first of all look at the methods of a
study really understand how they how
they sort of progressed through this
what were they those are hypotheses in
the first place did they have some sort
of preordained you know sort of
conclusion before they even started the
study how did that influence the
findings and and then to be able to take
that and and analyze it myself so in
some ways I'm taking existing knowledge
but then applying you know two decades
worth of analysis to it I think one of
the best examples for me and this is
something where I I learned something
personally because I think I was wrong
on this was medicinal marijuana yeah you
know it was it was not a thing that I
thought had you know frankly much merit
when I first looked at it but after I
was able to look at existing studies and
apply my own my own analysis my own
common sense my truly unconvicted you
know objective opinion and and thoughts
on this I reached different conclusions
so so you know that that's just that's
that's an example yeah it's existing
knowledge with with a healthy dose of
homework analysis and healthy skepticism
right well the marijuana example was was
a big deal when it happened
and you kind of made this formal apology
you know said I had said these things in
the past but now after you know
immersing myself and the science and
learning about all of this I've changed
my mind yeah and that made like
headlines around the world like oh my
goodness like doctor changes his mom yes
doctor what we were talking at the very
outset of the conversation it's like
science evolves yes learn as you go and
I worry about a culture in which we're
not allowed to change our mind right
yeah i 100% agree with you i mean you
know what kind of world would that be
where we just figured that we already
know it all yeah we're not gonna learn
anything new I I will say with with the
with the medical marijuana and cannabis
in general with all due respect to the
scientists that were out there you know
really pounding the drums on this long
before I change my mind I mean for them
they look at me and they say well yeah
you know what it wasn't that science
evolves so much it's that you know the
establishment both medical governmental
just bought into this idea that this was
a substance that was had was highly
toxic highly addictive and had no
medical benefit and it was a Schedule
one substance and everyone that's just
the way it is and oftentimes people
don't do do the extra digging you know a
lot of the data that I ended up really
looking at that that inform my new newly
changed mind was data that existed
it sometimes existed in labs outside the
United States existed in labs that were
not federally funded I mean when you
have a substance that is already you
know preordained is having no medical
benefit it's very hard to do research on
it it's illegal and the scientific
community is already saying you know go
look somewhere else there's nothing to
see here
and everyone bought into that yeah so
there's the cultural barriers and the
cognitive bias that that's right
prevents that realization from occurring
yeah and then you know by the way you
write something like I write when I
Cameron what the headline was but I
think it was like why I changed my mind
and I wrote this thing and you know I
wasn't sure how it was gonna be taken
and I wasn't sure housing be taken by
people who had read it as an op-ed piece
but I wasn't sure I was gonna be taken
by my colleagues in medicine and you
know I work in an academic university
how the Dean's and you know the the
leadership was gonna take it and it was
it was it was a little nerve-racking in
that regard in the end I was comfortable
with it because you know we spent a long
time doing this research mm-hmm it was
well sited and you know I had all the
all the sources for why I was saying
what I was saying but you know people
could still say hey look you became a
guy who's endorsing an illegal substance
that doesn't have any medical benefit
we're not sure that you should be X
practicing medicine anymore B being a
journalist or whatever you know so it
was it was it was it was it was tough
yeah you stuck your neck out my my
recollection of that moment was that it
was a big media event but it was
something that was ultimately embraced
I'm sure you got some marginal blowback
from some people but overall I think
people were you know were kind of
delighted yeah you were coming out in a
very public way to say this I think so
you know and and I think people who were
who were knowledgeable about this topic
but maybe had never really dug into the
science now had this this this article
you know that had all these citations
where you could spend a couple of hours
reading this and looking at the sources
and reading the studies and saying
Wow I kind of get it now I understand
why this could be medically beneficial I
understand what it does in the brain I
understand why it might help people with
inflammatory bowel disease with pain
disorders with epilepsy whatever it
might be like you could become
knowledgeable about this it wasn't just
a emotional argument that people were
making based on you know sort of the
reefer madness of the mid 30s right
early 40s whenever that was so it and
that was that was pretty pretty
gratifying I got these calls from some
calls that I you know to this day stick
with me from people in the medical world
who say look you can't talk about me
publicly but you know there's sort of
revered people in that world who came
out and said yeah I mean I gave this to
my father when he was suffering with
with the side effects of chemotherapy
and it really helped him more I saw how
this helped a kid with with refractory
seizures
you know who's having 300 seizures a
week I got a call from a judge in New
York someone who had actually been
responsible for putting people away you
know for the real sort of you know
criminal aspects of marijuana and who
recognized that maybe there have been
people who have been taking it for
medical reasons who had been you know
treated as criminals and person was very
upset and actually started weeping on
the phone so that some of that was
pretty powerful it didn't seem to follow
any particular political line gender
line young old I mean everyone everyone
in some ways had a story to tell and you
know that was that was pretty amazing to
me how do you make decisions about the
stories that you want to pursue it's you
know with there's there's always the
news aspect of it so things that are in
the news I think drive that that's the
biggest driver of what we do you know
things that are currently happening then
use and we'll look at opportunities to
to educate people more about an issue
because of something that's happening in
the news so like when you know Bill
Clinton had his heart operation right
people variant it because he's president
United States but here was an
opportunity to educate people about
heart disease but also about a
plant-based diet something that he had
adopted to try and control his own heart
health you know so that's it but the
news really ends up being a big driver
when you're doing a docu-series or a
series of you know longer form things
sometimes you have the the the luxury of
being able to look into things that are
totally totally enterprise right they
don't necessarily have any particular
news value in the current news cycle but
they're so interesting we think they're
so relevant they're gonna make some sort
of impact on people's lives that we
still do it right and so those are the
two big ways the news is the big tip of
the spear but the idea of being able to
do enterprise reporting about things we
find interesting is is also something
that we do quite a bit so what was the
thought process that went into the
newest series chasing life where you
traipse all over the globe trying to
unlock the secrets of health and
longevity well you should you would love
going on these trips I know you would
yeah I'm jealous I know it's it's it's
it's wild it's it's it's a lot of fun
it's it's really super interesting but
the but the basic thought process was it
was very simple in a way I love our
healthcare system in this country I'm a
member of it and I practice in it but I
also recognize that you know we spend 3
and a half trillion dollars on health
care and we don't get in return what we
should for that we we have dropping life
expectancy three years in a row or 23rd
in the world with with regard to life
expectancy behind Cyprus and Chile and
Costa Rica they're all ahead of us we're
expected to drop even further over the
next 20 years so there must be places
around the world where people are living
happier healthier better lives and we
are and I want to know what they're
doing I want to know how they're doing
it and to understand what really works
you know prove it and and bring those
stories back to to the viewers that was
that was it I think you know we live in
a really global world now I think when I
first started practicing medicine the
idea of you know some Far Eastern
tradition well that's that's that's
than fringe and crazy and acupuncture
and massage and all that and now we have
real data behind these things well
there's all sorts of thousands of
practices like this around the world
that we could learn from that are easily
incorporated into our lives and we could
benefit yeah
well it's exciting you go to India you
go to Japan
Bolivia Turkey yeah all these cool
noises yeah yeah yeah I mean it was it
was it was amazing yeah you know I got
to live in the middle of the Amazon
rainforest with an indigenous tribe in
Bolivia I spent time in mainland Japan
the most stressed country in the world
but also Okinawa where people live over
a hundred more than other places Italy
you know it's the healthy country
despite their their their love of food
and and alcohol and all that sort of
stuff how do they stay so healthy I you
know it was it was it was an amazing
experience for me I would have done it
if I didn't you know even if I didn't
have a series to produce I would have
still done these trips just to learn
yeah and what's interesting is that so
many of these kind of quote-unquote
secrets are you said it last night
they're like well it's kind of common
sense and it's kind of obvious like
they're just living more in alignment
with the natural rhythms of the earth
and the planet and they're in
environments that are conducive to
community and eating well and sleep and
yeah a reduction in stress and all of
these things that we have to combat our
environment to master I was probably the
most surprising thing to me is like even
when we were writing you know and
starting to tell the stories I thought
to myself several times you know this is
gonna make sense to people right because
this is so obvious some of this is so
obvious that we live the way humans
should live we move the way humans
should move we fuel our bodies the way
humans for most of our existence on this
earth have fueled their bodies that's
the way we evolved those are the
receptors in our body that's how we were
designed it sounded so obvious sometimes
and yet I would say these things and
people would say really wow that's
amazing I would have never thought that
yeah it's like well you should have
thought that because you know we are
about the blink of an eye in our human
existence and it doesn't take much
research to think about how
evolved and why we evolved the way that
we do I'm even going back to the canvas
thing we have cannabis receptors in our
body why are they there how did we
interact with our environment in a way
that would have evolved us to have
cannabis receptors in our body what do
they do how do we stimulate them you
know and there's there's countless
examples like that so I I got in some
ways to tell people something that was
so basic and so fundamental but needs
constant reminding yeah and profound
yeah and and and profound I mean I I
love the discussion around it because I
feel like it's totally defensible like I
get whatever we're talking about I can
explain really well not in terms of just
how it works why it works but the fact
that this is this is the way it should
work this is how we humans evolved and
it feels big if you know I feel humbled
by it in some ways yeah well my friend
you have a heart out and I'm gonna have
to let you go before I do that if you
can indulge me with one last question if
you if you suddenly became Surgeon
General of the United States which was
actually a very real possibility for you
you were very close even Obama wanted
you to become the Surgeon General you
ended up declining that amazing
opportunity but had you taken advantage
of that or should that ever become your
reality in the future what would be the
first order of business it's a two-hour
answer well that but there's so many
there's so many big important issues I
think that you know we're dealing with
in this country and I think you know
most the diseases that people are taking
care of in hospitals are totally
preventable due to lifestyle issues and
and the types of foods that we eat
I would certainly work on our food
policy which I think would change a lot
of the way that we look at medicine and
health and wellness overall I would
really beat the drum on our energy
policy in its impact on human health
some of the the regulatory or D
regulatory policies that are happening
now are frightening and and totally
unnecessary and will have a long-term
impact on human health those things that
the opioid crisis there's all these
things that you know I'd want to dig
into but I'll tell you one thing that
has surprised me and that I've learned
and that is the the the real toxic
impact of social isolation on our on our
emotional health our mental health and I
think in in terms of our outlook on the
world I mean we are dying in this
country deaths of desperation higher
than any other developed country in the
world it's self-inflicted deaths
essentially suicide overdose liver
cirrhosis due to alcoholism and and I
think a lot of it has to do with this
sort of psychic stress that we're
dealing with in this country and I think
social isolation loneliness lack of
community lack of social fabric is a is
a big part of that and I and I always I
hesitate a little bit when I say this
because I know it sounds sort of hard to
define around the edges fuzzy like what
does that mean exactly how would you
invest in in creating a social fabric
well I have all sorts of ideas on that
but one thing I would start off by
saying is that most countries around the
world do invest heavily in social fabric
making people feel like they have a true
safety net that they're not forgotten
that they're a part of something larger
than themselves and I think the impact
on physical health is something that we
are have learned so much about when you
live a life where you feel some sort of
predictability some sort of security
everything else follows from that like
the bigger problems mm-hmm well figure
we'll figure out the the big ones that
we're talking about but you want to
treat the root cause versus just the
symptoms that's one that I would focus
on for our generation and certainly for
the next generation as well yeah that's
a solid answer my friend all right all
right good I have to release you to your
life thank you so much for doing this I
just want to again acknowledge you for
the amazing work that you do you're an
inspiration to not only me but millions
of people all over the world and you
know I just love watching your career
from afar and it's an honor and a
privilege to know you and to talk with
you here today so thank you thank you
love you brother
all right love you too
chasing life on CNN what's next let's
chase life yeah all right let's come
back and talk to me again please
[Music]